so let's make things spicy and ask if if
bitcoin fails in the long-term future
as all you just said economics
volatility things happen in this world
well the human civilization might end
in this century
i hope it doesn't but it might there
could be catastrophic events
if bitcoin fails
it goes to zero loses its number one
spot
what would be the reason if you're
an alien visiting earth 100 years from
now and just were to analyze the
situation bitcoin is a pretty new thing
so the possible trajectories of how the
world evolves together with this new
monetary technology
is uh nearly infinite so if it fails one
of those trajectories surely involves
bitcoin failing what would be the reason
i think the most likely reason that it
could fail i don't think this is likely
in general but i think it is the most
likely of all the unlikely things that
could destroy bitcoin
is uh governments go back on a gold
standard
oh interesting so they make in your view
a better decision than the current
system just not the best decision
yeah and i thought you would go much
darker
but so that's yeah okay interesting so
maybe because of russia because of china
and so on because the current war
they might reconsider
the the power that america holds because
of the monetary
because of being the primary currency
and they'll start thinking about going
on the gold standard yeah but it would
also require the us and the europeans
and everybody to want to join in this
system and sing kumbaya and play uh nice
with each other around the gold standard
i think you know given that gold already
is about 10 times larger than bitcoin so
it has a first mover advantage yes
um
if governments were to go and peg their
currencies to gold again the price of
gold would shoot up um
five 10x
and it would rise in value a lot more of
course that doesn't necessarily kill
bitcoin
no again i'm not saying it's likely to
happen i'm saying it's i imagine less
likely
less unlikely than all the other
unlikely scenarios because you know even
with a nuclear war like
our half or 90 of the planet is
destroyed the 10 percent continue to run
bitcoin
there's a quote
you